a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up your dad said that he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
you
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel of the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and today is a great day we have
some awesome new spider-man 3 details
that we're going to get into we'll talk
about spider-man into the spider verse 2
and we just got a brand-new trailer for
spider-man Miles Morales the new game
announced for ps5 so if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can get all the
Marvel videos and so you can stay up to
date on everything happening within the
MCU also for this week's weekly giveaway
I'm givin away a Deadpool Funko pop all
you have to do to enter is be subscribed
to my channel like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below now I
know a lot of people are freaking out
about this spider-man ps4 is one of the
greatest Marvel games to offer right now
and you were able to play as Miles
Morales before but not that much and now
we have an entire game dedicated to him
and Peter Parker is most likely going to
be in this game as well just as miles
was in spider-man ps4 Peter Parker will
most likely be in spider-man Miles
Morales now what's really interesting
about the timing of the release of this
game is that we have spider-man into the
spider-verse 2 coming out in October of
2022 and of course this is going to be
starring Miles Morales with a whole
bunch of other spider-man as well and
this just kind of tells you where Marvel
and Sony's mindset is right now when it
comes to spider-man they are focused
right now on Miles Morales and this is
something that is most likely going to
bleed over into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Miles Morales making his MCU
debut later on down the line
right now we have Tom Holland playing
Peter Parker's version of spider-man but
it's widely speculated and has actually
been reported by some that we are going
to be getting a live action spider verse
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
this goes right along with Marvel
Studios this plan for a multiverse as
well that they're going to be
introducing in phase 4 they pretty much
already introduced it in Avengers in
game when they talked about the
different timelines of being created by
going back in time and changing certain
events and the Avengers definitely did
that and Avengers in game they created
different timelines despite Captain
going back in time putting the Infinity
stones back right where they took him
from in fact it's already been confirmed
that the Loki series is going to have
the TVA the time variance Authority in
the series and the TVA's sole
responsibility is to protect different
timelines from other timelines and other
people from other timelines and then
when we go into Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness the multiverse is
going to be blown up it's going to be
put into madness and from there the
possibilities of what's going to happen
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
multiple characters appearing from other
universes is endless and in fact
spider-man far from home kind of already
teased the arrival and possibility of
Miles Morales making a debut in the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe is mr. bet
we're gonna use someone like you on my
world new world Vic is from Earth just
not ours a snap to our home in our
dimension job to do you're coming with
us
so the multiverse was teased although it
didn't exactly end up being true but we
all thought before we saw the actual
movie that the multiverse was real it
finally made its way into the MCU and
Mysterio came from a different universe
from a different earth and this was
really Marvel's way of teasing what was
to come for the MCU because then they
announced Doctor Strange to multiverse
of madness confirming that the
multiverse does indeed exist in the MCU
now right now it's been claimed by the
famous account on Twitter Roger Wardell
the same account that was right about
all of the plot leaks for Avengers and
game all of which were 100% true well
Roger Wardell is now claiming this in a
recent tweet he said Disney understands
the money-making powers of spider-man
while Sony is aware of being completely
unable to compete with the mouse at the
moment new agreement should please many
Marvel fans so right now Marvel and Sony
are playing very well with each other
in fact not too long ago it was
announced that there's a mysterious
movie being made between Sony and Marvel
a spider-man spin-off now right now
nobody knows what this movie could be
and it may not be a Miles Morales film
but it could be a way to introduce him
because you have to remember that the
spider verse for the MCU and also for
Sony is ex
and they're sort of bleeding into each
other we have characters that are
crossing over now into different
universes we have vulture who originally
appeared in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe crossing over into the Morbius
trailer which exists in Sony's
spider-man universe
so clearly Marvel and Sony have a lot of
big plans that they're planning to do
together and we can clearly see where
their minds are at right now with Miles
Morales now on the other hand we do also
have some spider-man 3 details
unfortunately due to kovin 19 the
production on spider-man 3 which had
already started it was shut down along
with practically all of Sony's projects
and Marvel's projects as well but the
good news is is that most studios have
been given the green light to go ahead
and resume production on their projects
that had to be put on hold and this has
been given to most studios in most
countries this means that production for
spider-man 3 can resume again very very
soon and thanks to a recent report we
have an idea of when that will be
according to Charles Murphy from
Murphy's multiverse comm he says that he
has recently heard rumblings about the
production of spider-man 3 aiming for a
late September to early October start
date this is great because when
production again resumes we find out
more about the movie thanks to some
leaks not to mention the title shouldn't
be too far after that and side note in
regards to the spider-man 3 title right
now since we got the new announcement of
spider-man Miles Morales coming to PS 5
a lot of people are saying that a great
title for spider-man 3 could be miles
from home and there's theories going
around right now that since spider-man
is going to be on the run and he's going
to need some help in the film Miles
Morales would be the perfect person to
help him - spider-man's in one film he
could be from the same universe and the
same earth or he could be from a
different universe since that was kind
of set up and spider-man far from home
if they do end up introducing Miles
Morales and spider-man three miles from
home would be the perfect title but
what's very interesting about Marvel
Studios resuming production on
spider-man 3 is something else that
Charles Murphy heard he said that when
spider-man 3 starts production Tom
Holland might not actually be there for
the start of it for quite some time Tom
Holland was in the process of shooting
for uncharted another Sony film and the
studio says that they plan on beginning
production for that film in mid-july and
that's only a couple of months before
September when they would begin
production on spider-man 3 now according
to Charles Murphy the studio is going to
be stepping way outside of their comfort
zone to get things done but still they
need time for Tom Holland to film
uncharted which means when production
Begins for spider-man 3 Tom Holland is
most likely not going to be there for
the start of it now this could
potentially be quite revealing because
if Tom Holland isn't going to be there
for the start of production and filming
that means that there's a lot of other
scenes with a lot of other characters
that are going to be filming first and
that could mean that there could be
multiple villains in spider-man 3 since
so much filming has to happen before Tom
Holland actually gets there and this
could potentially mean and I want to
stress that this is pure speculation on
my part but it could potentially mean
that we could see the sinister six and
spider-man 3 it's been rumored for a
while now and if they are filming
multiple villains it just makes sense
now recently Marissa Tomei who of course
plays Aunt May and Captain America Civil
War
spider-man homecoming and spider-man
fight from home has opened up a little
bit about what to expect from Aunt May
in spider-man 3 while talking to Screen
Rant for her new film the king of Staten
Island she was asked about what
spider-man 3 will hold for on May and
although of course she couldn't reveal
much about the film she was able to
share her hopes for Aunt May story arc
in spider-man 3 and in the interview she
said well I've had her director John
watts and I have always talked about her
being a community organizer and
hopefully that track will expand and be
a part of this one as well now a
community organizer in spider-man 3
where Peter Parker is a wanted criminal
could mean that she's going to go around
in the community and get people to
believe that spider-man is actually
innocent they know who Peter Parker is
so they're gonna know that Aunt May is
his aunt so of course the authorities
are going to talk to her but of course
she's going to claim that he's innocent
and it sounds like she's going to get
the community involved the spider-man
community that believes spider-man is
good and get them involved and get them
all to try and help proof that he is
actually innocent so just a little
tidbit about what we can expect from
Aunt May's character so a lot of
exciting things happening with
spider-man we have a
new spider-man Miles Morales ps5 game
coming out and for those of you who have
been asking it yes I will stream it
along with the Avengers game when they
come out
production on spider-man into the spider
verse 2 has been announced and
production on spider-man 3 is going to
pick back up again in September or
October so let me know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man and of
course the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof